over on a secular talk our friend Kyle :
skis YouTube channel he covered a story
that we didn't cover which was
originally reported by salon about a
neo-nazi website going crazy when it was
revealed that the founder actually
married a Jew here's what Kyle had to
say about it check it out
Raw Story is reporting on an
unbelievable unbelievable story about
the far-right fringe on the Internet so
they explain here neo-nazi icon Mike
Enoch or anak however the [ __ ] you
pronounce it the pseudonym used by the
man who created the pro white
nationalist website the right stuff has
resigned from his role at the web site
after being outed by rivals as a New
York website developer named Mike Penev
itch pen avec the real shocker however
wasn't the identity of Penev ik but the
identity of his wife who happens to be a
Jewish woman
this is particularly surprising because
he often makes jokes about the Holocaust
on his podcast where he also regularly
talks about killing Jewish people in a
post on the right stuff's password
protected forums Mike Penev ik admitted
that he's married to a Jewish woman and
said he didn't want to see anyone making
excuses for his longtime deception of
his fellow white nationalists yes my
wife is who they say she is I won't even
bother denying it I won't bother making
excuses if this makes you want to leave
the movement or have nothing to do with
the right stuff then I understand don't
lie for me don't try to defend me to
those attacking me don't jeopardize your
own reputation by defending things that
you don't think you can this story is
just unreal and I feel horrible for that
poor woman man I mean you accidentally
married a [ __ ] neo-nazi and you're
Jewish oh oh but the part of the story
that I really am just so baffled by is
what is going on in
that guy's head because either he really
drank the kool-aid and he believes the
propaganda and he really hates all Jews
and he kinda wants to kill his wife or
on some level he knows that the toxic
neo-nazi ideology is utter [ __ ] and
it's laughably stupid in which case why
are you doing the website and why're you
a self-described neo-nazi so either way
the guy's a massive walking
contradiction and a confused ball of
anger and bad emotions so I don't know
what it is but what a bizarre situation
man when I watched Kyle's coverage of
this story and about Mike Enoch
I couldn't help but be reminded of when
this white separatist Craig Cobb was
outed and I used that term sort of as a
joke because obviously there's nothing
bad about this outed as being 14% black
you might remember Craig Cobb is the guy
who he spent a while in jail we
interviewed him about this whites only
Enclave he's trying to start in the
Dakotas I don't even remember the
specifics of it because it was so
harebrained and they did a DNA test of
him and it revealed that he was 14%
black and we did a story about it the
clip went completely viral and you know
that the interesting thing is the
supporters seem to always find a way to
defend whoever it is they want to defend
if they have the right ideas and a great
example of this is the alt-right still
loves Trump not all of them but a lot of
them still love Trump even though they
are very anti-semitic by and large and
Trump arguably has the most Jewish
family of any President of the United
States Trump's daughter converting to
Judaism Trump's trusted son-in-law Jared
Kushner Jewish his entire life so to
speak Trump's grandkids are Jewish and
because the alt-right sees Trump as the
closest that they'll get or at least
that they've gotten to
that they want all of a sudden those
realities become secondary and it's
interesting that in this particular case
the website went completely crazy a
great job by kyle covering it check out
Kyle's full coverage of the story by
clicking the link in the description to
this video